[Music]
on the dish this morning chef rich
theresi and his most recent Spot theresi
bar and restaurants a reboot of one of
his older restaurants but on a much much
bigger scale it's all part of teresi's
bold approach while his Partners in the
major food group started focusing on
trendy destinations including South
Florida Theresa has gone all in on the
new New York and he put down for us one
of the best spreads we have ever tasted
did you ever think when that closed
you'd be like I want to do this again
um no I thought I I probably don't want
to do this again rich theresi is giving
his first love a second chance
the original Theresa Italian Specialties
was a tiny Gem of a spot that opened in
2009 and led to the creation of the
major Food Group which now owns
restaurants around the world including
Carbone and cidels
theresi closed in 2015 but Rich became
determined to bring it back and did so
in a space
10 times as large there's opening a
restaurant as like a little Art House
movie and then there's trying to open a
restaurant as a blockbuster 100 you're
trying a blockbuster 100 but my hope is
that it's a blockbuster that it still
has high level craft and art
um inside of it Theresa grew up just
outside New York City and said he knew
food would be his life when he was five
his grandmother played a big role in
raising him
Grandma Angie is currently a hundred and
two years old and joined us by the
kitchen as Rich prepared one of his
signatures duck ala Mulberry is this
your favorite dish
it's definitely a dish that's caused me
to gain the most weight
there's no doubt about that is she
allowed to critique the dishes she she's
going to do it whether she's allowed to
or not that's what she's been doing for
a very long time
she'd probably say that I'm going to
make a mess as well what
who's going to clean up
how do you think he's doing excellent
Theresa serves his carefully selected
duck over fresh mustard with Mulberry
sauce look at that Swiss chard and
orange zest
that's fantastic it looks beautiful yeah
and it smells amazing delicious fish you
like it very good
this is the first time I've had duck
yeah I've had 102. not a bad time to
have it yeah 100 and so
duck ala Mulberry is one of those dishes
that theresi has experimented with
relentlessly he is stubborn introverted
unafraid
his restaurant Partners have shifted
much of their focus to South Florida
said respectfully
no
I'm quadrupling down on New York because
because I felt it I was going space to
space and I thought
you know anyone that business knows this
the best time to strike is when things
look the worst
Theresa is located in the historic Puck
building which was built in the 1890s
and was once the home of the famed
satirical magazine of the same name when
we walked down inside the building we
have the vaulted ceilings the cast iron
columns these gigantic Windows these
design features they're one in a million
and that's what we look to do at the
restaurant we looked at just really
highlight the amazing things that our
space had that other spaces just don't
have today the puck building is the
canvas for teresi's creativity which
included cucumbers New York Casey meant
to remind you of the flavors found in a
classic New York Pickle Barrel
octopus not Trang inspired by a nearby
Vietnamese restaurant that Theresa
frequents
Italian and American hams with zeppole
these are zeppole that we tried to order
so the idea is you took is Epley you
take a little bit of this pineapple
light very light yeah super light take a
little bit of this pineapple
we call them a startup it's made with
mustard seeds mustard oil you take a
piece of the ham and you just kind of
let it fold right on top of the zeppole
and you eat it
that's awesome
we get to Showcase things two hams that
are
radically different from each other this
ham is from Kentucky it's done in the
traditional American Way
salt cured it's smoked
right this ham is from outside bologna
from a small town It's Made In
traditional Parma Italian way
it's cured weight longer softer it's
more delicate
there was also tortellini Pomodoro and
bass dugana
accompanied by the house Negroni a dirty
martini and a grapefruit and tonic
cheers thank you thank you fantastic
for dessert an indulgent affogato it's a
simple matter of a little bit of fudge
mascarpone moose in between and a nice
thick layer of the espresso granita on
top also frozen yogurt served in a
pomelo shell with a jam made of Campari
and grapefruit
a sicilian date cake
and almond cheesecake
you don't dream small no
huge it's amazing it's big every dish
it's like trying to hit it out of the
park
a dream
as big as I could possibly dream because
I feel like what's the downside
I feel like
as long
as you can legitimately believe it
that's kind of the rule I hold myself to
when I'm Dreaming as long as I can
believe
that that I can make it real
then it doesn't matter to me how big it
is because the belief the belief is the
most important thing about a dream to
have tons of dreams but if you like to
believe it doesn't matter at all you're
never you'll never get it
I just thought that was such a great
point a lot of people have dreams but if
you don't believe and you don't take it
I mean what people say we never get days
back and it's true right but if you're
not taking action that career you want
doesn't matter how do you want to pursue
the book you want to write whatever it
is do it yeah right yeah take that first
step and I and because there's nothing
here I I owe you I you're taking us
doing a three threesome dinner
[Laughter]
and the restaurant looks so beautiful I
kept saying that the food looks amazing
but look how gorgeous that space there
it is